[Music]
Keith Urban is gearing up to drop his
eighth studio album called ripcord on
May 6 on Thursday the country star
opened up to et about the new record and
revealed how his wife nicole kidman
influences his creativity will there be
any love songs for Nicole or the girls
on the new album well I mean all the
love songs I'm drawing from a particular
place it's a very diverse record it
really is there's there's there's songs
about being in the moment about life
there's songs about reminiscing and
there's songs about love songs about
love loss there's a song on the record
hopefully called that could still be
asked which is I think a lot of people
don't relate to that song
you said you asked a lot of people for
their opinions on what songs make the
final cut do the girls chime in not so
much y'all though no but I mean you know
and Nick Accorsi is everything over the
course of about 15 months I've been
working on this record so she's heard
everything over and over and over again
god bless her picking favorites maybe I
like well interesting is a lot of the
times I I'm interested how I respond
just when she's listening without her
saying anything I have a particular
response that's not necessarily the same
without her so it's important I need the
girl views